this course is about crypto  but it's unlike any other crypto course  you're likely going to see anywhere else  it's not going to teach you how to code  crypto it's definitely not going to  teach you how to trade crypto and make a  billion dollars here and lose a billion  dollars there  this is a course about the future of  crypto as a technology as a force in  society and as a mechanism that  regulators are going to have to grapple  with  in all candor nobody knows how this  story ends but we do know many of the  serious questions that are going to have  to be asked and answered as we grapple  with the future of crypto as a  technological force in our society  join us on this adventure and we look  forward to cooperating with you and  bringing you a different perspective a  different way of thinking about the  future of crypto